excellent goût peu toulousain alors
voient leur bonne humeur et leur entrain
a déjà conquis les foules et fait danser
de nombreux spectateurs à travers
l'hexagone
il sera en concert le 1er mars à
l'estaminet à magny les hameaux
voici les bombes 2 bal dans le kiosque
le vin est bon de balle et un crochet
qui est à l'origine de claude sicre un
de l'association escambiar à cluj l'idée
c'est de faire danser entre elles toutes
générations de mélanger tous les a
rejeté de les faire un cerf le plan
blanc rendant au couple enchaîne haye et
la rendre encore nos cousines en vente
son mais près d'un fort coup de vent et
le fait droit qu elles ont même proposé
lendemain il faut leur taper
l'espace est lâchée au projet des bobos
de bâle a été conçu comme une équipe de
foot recettes via les titulaires les
robes la fin et ce qui compte c'est
vraiment le projet le répertoire équipe
tourne depuis 12 ans ne s'est pas
forcément les mêmes joueurs
j'ai pas laver la voiture heureusement
cela nous plaît ma tête pour la bo va
voir avait la voiture j'ai laissé les
éraflures
je m'appelle à pépieux et voilà les
frictions langue j'ai à boucler ma
ceinture j'ai manqué sur la répercussion
en effet l accordéon violon une vaste un
banjo et les percussions qui ya une
grosse bombe un triangle un abobo et
puis voilà on est trois chanteurs et
puis il ya des garçons qui sont des
coeurs aussi
ça
abu rahma chez chacun
d'une manière de chanter ensemble
d'anciens temples c'est vraiment offrir
enfin partager c'est le partage voilà
c'est partager avec les gens des ce
qu'on me demandait le faire dans ce
genre de partage et à la malbaie mamadou
faye bismes abega navega el-khazen
facebook
maninona no enfin la fille d'un soldat
allemand et hd mois en effet comme
chaque année de faire donc ces gens ont
faim mais c'est notre mission et notre
preview donc en fait ce qu'on fait est
que des gens dans les répertoires qui a
pu travailler très réfléchis donc par
claude qui directeur artistique des
bombes 2 bal claude sicre atteint et
ensuite on a aussi elle prouve que de 27
initiateur donc qui est dans le public
et qui montre les pas aux gens et qui
forme des rondes carrées d'antan mois et
cette légende dit long ça va être dur si
on n'aime pas trop d'entre elles en fait
il y fait plus ou moins tout le monde
s'y met et on n'est pas là pour juger
pour faire des performances on est juste
là pour partager son temps et s'amuser
janvier est maintenant un nouveau sujet
de la rédaction brister où brice brice
brice oui oui
une piste de danse envahi par des
cowboys un bal concert organisé par
l'association cow boy advance heures de
plaisir boîte chapeau et veste sur le
dos tous sont prêts à danser les 4,7
prévus pour l'occasion
au total 200 personnes réunies autour
d'une même passion la poudre
j'étais aux états unis j'ai vu des gens
danser écouter la musique et je me suis
dit c'est pas la même chose en rentrant
donc j'ai pris des cours et puis après
j'ai créé mon association est maintenant
sont des courses fait des balles ça fait
sept ans pour la première année
l'association a fait appel à franck
silver musiciens et professionnels de
country c'est une passion
et ça nous a permis de nous aussi de
joindre l'utile et l'agréable
ça fait longtemps qu'on fait de la
musique je suis passionné de cette
culture là depuis longtemps mais on a
réussi à joindre les
l'utile et l'agréable depuis quelques
années outre ce mal pendant l'année
l'association propose des cours de
country association de danse uniquement
mais tous ceux qui aiment la musique la
musique country exactement alors sur
toutes les formes le rockabilly le
bluegrass le outlaw donc plein de sortes
de musique country pour tous les
intéressés
le prochain bal ouvert aura lieu en mai
prochain le droit d'entrée est de 10
euros
et encore quelques dates à retenir avant
de brancher le sport elec
le 23 février vous pouvez profiter d'une
soirée django héritage parle de noé
reinhardt trio au prix smile en cour le
24 c'est les fameux jamie adkins qui
présentera circus incognitus à la merise
attrape et les 28 février et 1er mars la
mezzo-soprano karine deshayes et opera
fuoco dirigé par david stern proposeront
cantate romantique au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines des dates que
vous pouvez retrouver ainsi que
l'ensemble de la programmation
culturelle des salles saint-quentinoise
dans le kiosque sur internet aux
adresses qui s'affiche alors à bientôt
et n'oubliez pas que tous les mardis
vous pouvez gagner des places de
spectacle sur le site www.skype.com qui
point fr